So when it's all said and done prepare to have 20 to 30 beautiful
women,
you get to select from like a dollar menu at McDonald's.
I'm not so sure you want to be taking this guy's advice. You know,
the dollar menu, I mean, comes in clutch in a pinch, but, um,
I don't, I don't know that that's the type of, I don't know.
Like a dollar menu and McDonald's,
let me tell you a little about who the hell I am.
Oh boy, here we go again guys, if you don't know who the hell this is,
this is Adrian G. We talked about him in our last video,
but he's back and better than ever. Last time he was telling us how to get rich.
Boy.
You had to make six figures a year by working just one day a week from your
laptop.
This time he's telling you how to get laid.
I'm a world renowned dating group.
This man is apparently an expert in the art of pickup.
He's an artist. They call themselves pickup artists in this community.
They charge insecure men,
a lot of money to teach them how to be more confident with the ladies.
My name is Adrian grew Shaw, but since we soon share a brotherhood,
you can just call me Adrian G or G.
That's right. You're about to join the simp brotherhood,
the nights of the single table, the fellowship of the cell.
But this guy in particular, it's shady.
He's given off some serious, um, B vibes. Some serious. Yes.
Means no vibes. If you catch my drift.
Well,
I've been teaching guys how to bag the world's sexiest women like groceries for
the past four weeks.
Yes. And there's warning, flag. Number one
bag and Wayman like groceries. Adrian. That's a little creepy. My man,
it's weird.
I've been calling your women like they're from a McDonald's dollar menu.
Very strict.
I got online and feverish. He began studying all the greatest pickup artists,
such as mystery, Neil Strauss, JT, Tran,
and plenty of others until I couldn't stop my brain anymore.
I was now programmed to learn and master the art of dropping panties.
Without me even asking.
Are you trying to meet to yourself right now?
They're going to look back on this.
Like we should have known all the things he was saying here.
We should have known all the lock adds a little suspicious,
very suspicious. But if you can believe it, it gets even worse. Imagine.
All work that goes into creating a new cure for a disease.
No, all the field tests and clinical trials.
No, don't do it. Don't compare yourself to a scientist.
And that is the level I was doing. This maniac or research.
Ah, there he goes.
He's trying to give himself the Nobel prize pick up right now. Relax.
You're a narcissistic 20 year old. You're not Einstein, but believe it or not,
it gets even worse.
And just kept on learning and interacting and testing out thousands of methods
on my new prey. Hello?
Nine 11 group.
Imagine calling yourself the master of women and then calling them prey
and saying you're bagging them like groceries, dude,
this guy has never done anything, but play some kind of wife who simulator.
This guy has no experience with real women. Actually, I take that back.
I've been looking into it fast forward future Steven year,
actually he does have some experience with women.
He has experienced hiring actors for his pranks, in fact,
cause he ran a social experiment channel. He's one of these guys,
but he actually got caught out for some of his pranks pranks, right? Uh, for,
for them being absolutely fake.
Oh, video's a lie. Cause everyone. Yeah. That's an actor. Yeah.
But you haven't revealed that to anyone. Yeah. Right. Is that right? I mean, no,
that's not right.
Yeah. My man is caught in the act and he goes, yeah, that's right. Wait, wait,
no. Uh, wait, uh, what was it.
Question? This is the girl at Glen elk.
Let tells you this is one of the other girls. They're all actors.
They all follow your profile, your acting profile on style.
Now that's just creepy, dude. I think we're done. We.
Need those kinds of reporters in America. Where are those reporters?
That's nice. Seriously. That's just creepy. What do you do that?
It turns out all that methodical research he was doing was looking for actors.
He's admitted. This clip too was staged
as were others.
Here's an ad looking for girls to be in another video with offers of a cash
payment.
This is the guy we're dealing with guys. This is the pickup master. Anyways,
guys, let's get back into the, into the video.
To be honest in this economy,
I had originally planned to give the system away for absolutely.
The free he's going to try to justify it voice.
Tell me if you think his justification makes any sense. Okay. He,
he wants to give it to you for free.
That is until I realized such a move would turn out to be counterproductive and
ruin the mission of what I actually set out to.
Do you see if this info was given away,
it would saturate the Bay market and your stock would crash.
My man's out here on some NASDAQ. He's uh, he's the standards and Poor's man.
I call it the potential Bay bubble and that C
yes.
He's worried about the great 2008 babe crash. Again,
he doesn't want to be responsible for that. So he's doing the only thing.
He knows how and charging outrageous sums of money for obvious.
And that is why I made the decision.
I must charge for this program for your protection.
Can't you just feel his sincerity there. I must charge for this program.
I'll be honest. This pickup artistry stuff.
Pretty freaking weird women pick up on this kind of stuff they can tell when
you're thinking to yourself, Ooh, look at what my new praise doing.
You're going to smell it on you from a mile away. Not going to go well.
So anyway,
I just wanted to share that with you guys have a little laugh with me about the
insanity of Adrian G anyway, that's it for now.
And don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.
[inaudible].